hey guys this is andrew for trading
sensors.com so i'm a professional trader
and i've been working for several big
investment banks like hsbc or commerce
bank
in the past five years in hong kong and
i've just started to make some
youtube videos where i mostly talk about
technical analysis and i try to show you
guys everything i see at work
all the different techniques that we
have to analyze market movements
so i know that a lot of you guys maybe
think like all right technical analysis
is [ __ ] this is not working because
markets are efficient
well that's not true market are not
efficient
and there are a lot of ways to actually
take advantage of different situations
by using some very
adapted and powerful tools and this is
technical analysis
so of course there is no way to be
hundred percent sure of what's going to
happen
but trading is not being always right
it's about making money
it's about being more right than wrong
it's about expected gains and
probabilities
in this video bring you into my world so
you're gonna need to use your
imagination and i'm going to show you
some real
life examples that illustrate why
technical analysis is working
because of actually the different
psychological mechanisms that are behind
it
and trust me that after watching this
video you're gonna see things very
differently and you're gonna understand
why technical analysis
is working let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so like i said you're gonna
need in this video to use a bit your
imagination
let me bring you into my world and i'm
gonna try to explain to you guys why
technical analysis
is working by using uh actually some
psychological mechanisms that all the
investors have
for example let's imagine that the
market is
actually a giant battlefield right and
you have buyers and sellers that every
day they fight for what they think
is right they think that the stock
should be higher so they'll just buy it
all right so the ammunition they use is
actually money
and where they're going to put this
money they're going to put it in the
different stocks that they're going to
use so stocks are weapons
so we are at war every day this is what
what is happening on the markets and
actually technical analysis
is like a survival kit for example you
have like first aid medicine
you have a compass that is going to help
you to identify where is the camp of the
bulls
and the camp of the bears it's going to
tell you as well when it's time to
retreat
if for example a resistance has been
broken and you were a buyer
you know that it's time to take your
loss to like just cut your position
and not get wiped out because this is
what happens on the market some people
they lose everything
and it's like you know you don't want to
be this dead body that they're going to
find on the battlefield the day after
because they
just you know they couldn't leave
sometimes it's time to retreat you need
to know it
and you need to do it in order to
participate in the next battle
all right so technical analysis is what
is going to help you to identify the
support and
the resistance levels because this is
what it is all about
and to know for example where to buy
your entry level at the support level
the target is going to be the next
resistance level and you're gonna put
your stop loss just behind your
support or resistance depending if
you're a buyer or a seller
all right so now let me go a bit deeper
so stay with me follow me guys
and let's imagine and i really see
things
this way this is my vision when i do
technical analysis when i trade on the
markets this is what i see
i see that the market price is actually
alive
to me it's like a living being it has
emotions it has memory
you know just like a plant i mean plants
don't have emotions
maybe they do but for sure they have
memory and what is the plant
trying to do it's just trying to grow
all right
and this will make sense because like
for example the market price
actually reflects the development of
humans economy
all right so it's actually just
reflecting the development
of the man so it's indeed something that
is
growing that is trying to grow and that
has sometimes
uh some obstacles that it needs to
overcome in order to get bigger to get
stronger so this is what is happening
and look for example there is a very
famous indicator that i love to use
it's called fibonacci you know so
fibonacci is a famous
mathematician from the 12th century
and he understood that everything that
is growing is actually following some
patterns all right so you have this
golden number
1.618 and everything that is growing
actually is a ratio
of this number for example when a plant
is growing the different leaves they're
going to have this ratio between them
so the next leaf is going to be you know
bigger than the first one
so on and so forth and this is how a
plant is developing and this is as well
those the same reasons
uh that make that fibonacci ratio are
working on the market because the market
is
actually the same thing it's just
something that is alive
it is alive guys and it is trying to
grow so let me take the example of the s
p
500 to better illustrate what i mean so
here
you had the u.s presidential elections
so this is the s b 500 this was in
november and you had this very strong
rally here
and we were actually trading above the
all-time high so here
it so we had some kind of you know a
consolidation at this level
and then suddenly it got broken so here
you know that this was resistance it
becomes support
you have this very huge gap up yeah it's
very huge
and then we are in the no man's land
there is no it's it's a new all-time
high
but some uh people decided that it's
time to take profits all right it's
their decision and they were followed by
more people
all right only one guy is selling is not
enough on the s p 500 you had
a massive selling pressure that started
to occur here
you know it took some time because it's
never
it never happens right away i am on the
hourly time frame so in a matter of
one two three four five hours the the
selling pressure
was too harsh for the buyers to fight
back
so the market got rejected quite
brutally so when you are rejected
brutally
maybe it happened to you guys i don't
know which kind of situation but it all
happened to us to get rejected brutally
physically to get beaten up
this is what happened to the market here
this is what happened to those buyers
all right and this left a very strong
mark
this leaves a memory you remember what
happened in this area
and when you get back to it uh you're
scared you're scared
even if you don't show it you're scared
you got beaten up you're scared
so what are you gonna do if this
situation happens to you in the real
life
you go back to your friends you go back
to take some fresh ammunition
to get some fresh weapons you reload and
you fire back all right
this is what you would do if you were at
war and this is actually what those
buyers are doing they go back to the
to the camp to the bull camp they take
some fresh energy
which is actually liquidity which is
money and they use this money to fire
back
and they go back to this battle uh field
that is just above to the next
resistance level and look
they're not even touching it they get
rejected so here the bears are in
control
they're very strong they know that it's
their camp and that they have enough
ammunition
not to get beaten uh right now but
this is why you always have this kind of
buildup guys when you have new levels to
overcome
new resistance level you know you're
never gonna blow right through it and
then it's done you blew
right through it and then you have this
battle this is the consolidation that
can last for a few days
or even a few weeks all right this lasts
a few weeks and then same thing the
market comes back here
gets some new buyers and then gets
back to the resistance level where you
can see it resisted for
you know a few hours here and then
suddenly it got broken up
and this is the beautiful thing but just
one more thing i want to say here
is like why the sellers they were
confident here
it's actually some guys that were
confident that made money but it's
mostly guys that were long here
and that didn't sell all right so how do
you think they felt here you know
if this happens to you if you are long
this stock goes very high
everybody's happy some of your friends
are selling you're not selling and then
the
the market loses three percent and you
lose all the profits you made
you feel very bad you feel stupid you're
full of regrets
and those regrets are what gonna drive
you actually to take a different
decision
you're like oh i should have sold here
so if the opportunity happens again
here two weeks later so you know that's
why
market has memory because two weeks
later
the same level is gonna uh work it's
gonna act as
resistance again because those sellers
that didn't manage to take the profits
they're gonna say all right it's the
right time for me to take my profits
funny thing is that usually when
resistance is tested like
three four times it becomes weaker
buyers uh
get confidence and they usually manage
to
break it usually with the gap up so this
is what happened
here this is what happened here as well
you have this gap up we gap above the
resistance level
and we just retest it and go higher and
the beautiful thing about technical
analysis guys
is that once this resistance level is
broken it becomes
support and it's going to be the same
thing happening again
and you can see here you see retested
here then we go higher we come back here
once again who is buying here so it
might be the guess that we're buying
here but most likely it's all the
sellers that here
feel so wrong they feel like i'm not in
this battle you know
uh the guys are just uh everybody's
making money
the bulls are ma are winning and i want
to participate in this battle
but guys if you don't you know put your
money and your energy into a battle you
won't get the benefits of it it's not
going to be for you
if you want to be into it you need to
fight you need to put your money so this
is what they're going to do they're
going to start to buy here
even by more here and they're going to
be on the right side
all right guys so i hope i managed to
explain to you guys how i see
things and this is really how i see it
all right it's a constant battle
and you only need to know who is in
control
who has more ammunition you know it's
always about flows about
money to finding the right support and
resistance levels
and to understand when a battle is won
and when the battle is lost
all right so that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click the like
sub and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys